tu es le sport idéal pour les petits
Parisiens
on dit c'est une grande mode mais je
crois que ça va rester
voici Colbert
champion du monde de descente et de
slalom
[Applaudissements]
Mike oui champion du monde de figure
libre
ils sont venus à Paris pour quelle
raison ils sont venus à Paris au cours
d'une grande tournée qui font en Europe
et ça leur permet de montrer un petit
peu aux Français ce que c'est que le
skateboard aux États-Unis vous avez vu
la démonstration des champions
américains qui sont venus cette semaine
on peut pas le faire on pourra le faire
mais non dans quelques années hormis le
Stadium de Vitry où nous sommes
aujourd'hui à quel endroit peut-on
pratiquer le skate je crois que
l'endroit le plus populaire à Paris pour
l'instant
pourquoi vous avez choisi le Trocadéro
pour venir faire du skateboard parce que
il y a des pentes et c'est plats puis je
mets que dans le faire dans la rue aussi
c'est moi dangereux ah oui c'est moi
dangereux qu'est-ce qu'il faut comme
équipement pour en faire
tout spécialement il faut avoir un
casque
quand on veut freinez avec les mains
c'est c'est le casque parce que c'est
pas tellement
évident ouais depuis combien de temps
existe le skateboard aux États-Unis le
skateboard est pratiqué vraiment
couramment depuis une dizaine d'années à
peu près aux États-Unis
son c'est leur métier de faire ce Skype
professionnel du skateboard c'est-à-dire
que tous les deux travaillent dans ce
métier mettent au point des skateboard
même et travaille également dans le
design la présentation de ces appareils
en France on connaît le Sky depuis très
peu de temps maintenant
deux ans mais c'est surtout cette année
qu'il a connu sous c'est un dérivé du
ski ou du pâté à roulettes
ni l'un ni l'autre c'est un dérivé du
onceurfing c'est-à-dire de la planche à
voile en France
l'origine du skateboard c'est hawaïen je
crois
c'est les Américains qui ont pris ça
[Musique]
c'est le sport idéal pour les petits
Parisiens
on dit c'est une grande mode mais je
crois que ça va rester
du skateboard
où il y a des enfants en face du jardin
le slalom il y a un très bon jeu de
jambes
on peut tout faire et quelle est la
figure la plus dure à réussir il y en a
plein hein
on peut commencer faire du skate à
partir de quel âge sans danger lui là
par exemple il a 3 7 ans je crois
il en fait déjà
il descendent il fait la descente
à un véritable phénomène populaire
depuis depuis l'été dernier on est rendu
combien de planches depuis l'été dernier
je crois que dernière statistiques il a
été vendu environ 400000 planches sur la
France c'était énorme quel est le prix
d'une planche
varie généralement entre 150 francs et
1000 francs pour les plus chers
de
déroute quelles sont les qualités que
Vous demandez à une planche par exemple
pour la vitesse il faut qu'elle soit
assez longue il y en a qui préfèrent
rigide
ou flexible ça ça dépend de chaque
personne c'est pas un équilibre c'est la
personne elle-même qui choisit il y en a
même qui font leur planche même
[Musique]